[Music]
i realized i have a lot of [ __ ]
vietnamese friends because as long as
they're not girlfriends videos people
are awesome
that's why he got filipino wow i learned
so much about vietnamese they were crazy
dude they're pretty scary they are scary
i got divorced for one so i got it
um so
some sad news has come through for the
world wrestling community
and it is hall of famer
scott hall has passed away at the age of
63. razor ramon dude razor ramon
at 63.
and the greasy uh curly hair that always
comes down here that you used to like
draw dude he was dope bro he had jerry
curls and [ __ ] well he's a hulk
i always thought it was like a ramirez
or something it was because it was razor
ramon yeah yeah ramona
that's his name
ramirez ramirez there it is
ramirez
i kinda like that better actually
so uh um it was reported that uh hall
had suffered a fall and a subsequent
broken hip earlier this month
before undergoing surgery and the issue
had caused serious implications
involving blood clots which allegedly
led to three heart attacks
oh my gosh and hall being placed on life
support is that a steroid thing you
think it could be there's a lot of
people with prior yeah with prior
steroid use it enlarges the heart it
gets fat deposits so a lot of people
that have taken a ton of steroids will
have like enlarged hearts heart problems
and stuff like that and is this
something that like let's say you're off
of it at an older age right
and then like you can still suffer from
the previous like doses yeah yeah some
of the stuff's irreversible wow is it
because steroids also increase the size
of your internal organs some of them
depends on what you take so there's like
so many and then everyone has their own
like concoction that they put together
it's like their own personal juice
cleanse mix honestly yeah yeah but yeah
they all have their own concoctions and
you know especially if you're in an
entertainment like that like you're even
more incentivized because you're making
money off of your usage right so you
want to be bigger bad or stronger and
these guys man they're doing like shows
every night like john cena was doing
like 300 shows a night where you're body
slamming people and you have to still
train you know so like a lot like
all banged up yeah a lot of these guys i
see why they actually take it a lot of
pressure yeah and then um but then when
you have that much and you're pretty
much like cranking your body's
physiology to the max
there's just a lot of you know even with
the car you have exhaust right like it
takes air and then it burns the gas and
you have exhaust the exhaust is put back
into your body you know and so you have
like like plaques like you have like
arthritic
losses and then you have like that was
actually
yeah like there's when you said exhaust
i was thinking about a butthole but i
understand where you're going with that
yeah we're all thinking about like waste
products right like you know carbon
dioxide that's like a waste product but
there's internal waste products too that
just stays in there well said it's the
fitness guru yeah did everybody here
watch wwe or wwf grown up i did wwf but
i stopped after like the earliest one
like like bam bam bigelow million dollar
man yeah
remember that night the snake yeah the
look at the steamboat dragon come on
yeah dude he was the best
i think that was your asian
representation that's true i didn't even
see that game it was funny gold dust no
reason gold dust is hilarious yeah
always funny there was an asian wwe guy
yeah www back in a bit back in the day
can you look it up what's his name ricky
the steamboat dragon yeah he was pretty
good that was like when we were kids and
like we were all on the bruce lee and
stuff like that was he jacked or he's
like bruce lee like wasn't there a
karate guy
well i know remember i remember there
was a yokozuna
there was a lot of polynesians right
yeah yeah but
oh damn he's [ __ ] jacked he looks
kind of looks like bart dude nah dude
that's the bart damn
the dragon he reminds me of that the tim
guy ricky steamboat that's his name yeah
he would jump off the top rope bro from
the top rope why is his name steve last
name though because that was his stick
that wasn't yeah he's [ __ ] big there
was like fresh off the boat i don't know
some stupid [ __ ]
fresh off the steamboat the ff is like
and i don't know what it is now because
i haven't watched it in a while it was
like this it was like a saturday morning
thing yeah so we get up saturday morning
watch saturday morning cartoons and the
ones afternoon it was when wrestling was
and you know like oh man wrestling was
like so fun background
mattress on the ground and everyone just
starts [ __ ] each other we do all the
moves with each other sharp shooters
pile drivers [ __ ] tombstones it was
the best one you really thought it was
real even the even the video games were
like all like video games were fun
million dollar man was the weakest dude
you remember that
all you do is just slap and stuff yeah
well they always because they always
made hulk hogan the strongest yeah he
was the best yeah that was my favorite
era though
yeah i always enjoyed the uh the
ultimate warrior yeah oh yeah i was
thought he was cold he he died early too
yeah
yeah undertaker sick as [ __ ] and and
kane was at his brother
yeah i stopped watching after that the
undertaker era really yeah i could get
it so you didn't get into like
stonehenge boston and then the rock nah
i didn't get into that yeah i got into
like watching karate rock arrow was a
good arrow i'm cold in the rock stone
cold and the rock was like
that was like what i think really really
popularized it because even beforehand
outside of like saturday morning and
stuff like that which this is also like
semi like uh you didn't have things like
satellite or or like everybody didn't
have cable yeah um but when it got
really popular and people started having
things like cable and a bunch of other
[ __ ] the things that kept it mainstream
were things like [ __ ] stone cold in
the wrong is that the attitude era which
ones yeah yeah i think so yeah i think
so yeah that's when people just break
[ __ ] all the time how old do you think
kids age out of it because i aged out of
it in elementary school i would go now
and have a good time oh
there's ufc fighters now that are like
just found like ronda rousey's been fans
of wwe wwf for a long time
a lot of them transition
but i mean i would say i would say like
what nick was saying um there's a period
of time where you still believe it's
real
yeah and there's an argument it's like
obviously if you're jumping from a
ladder or you're being broken into it is
real the art of it's [ __ ] real yeah
but other than that when you really
think it's not scripted or choreographed
yeah man that's just crazy i went to a
gcw uh event like a couple weeks ago oh
[ __ ] yeah like the underground like type
of things uh yeah it's kind of like what
it felt like it was like between ecw and
like wwe they they're pretty hardcore
it's hardcore but the cool thing is like
watching it like as a super grown man
today it's you respect it for way more
levels yeah you just like these guys are
busting ass to make a good show
and it's so like you appreciate the [ __ ]
out of it like real fun like really good
professional wrestling is really [ __ ]
good like it's really fun to watch but
when you watch the guys that can't
really perform that well in the ring
you're like this is garbage oh yeah for
sure it's like an athletic play right
yeah yeah the final match was 40 minutes
long these guys were kicking ass beating
the [ __ ] out of each other dude gcw
shows bomb dude it's like it's your job
basically like if you're in the like in
the seats you have to know when they're
gonna [ __ ] rush off the stage and
you've gotta move yeah cause they're
[ __ ] with you it's your [ __ ] job
to move because they will just slam the
[ __ ] into everybody dude we should go to
one dude april 9th i'm going again let's
go i love how he just queued up the date
yeah yeah
we're all we're all like
childhood we're like yeah when we're
kids and he's like april knight let's go
because i i've never been to one live
until two weeks ago like i never got
what the heck yeah we should totally go
and then it blew my mind i was like i
didn't know that they work that [ __ ]
hard like it's insane i remember i was
in middle school and this is when i
learned professional wrestling wasn't
real as far as like it's not like you
don't fight somebody with uh wrestling
moves and that's that's the world
what crazy
you didn't do the people people's elbows
i was like dude you can't you got to
throw the arm dude i was getting a fight
with this this mexican dude
i was trying to get in a fight with this
dude named bob in the locker room
because we were like bullying each other
and [ __ ] and i tried to like [ __ ] hit
him with like the the sweet champ music
like what shawn michaels would do and
then he was like he pointed at me he was
like hey like
that's that's from wrestling and i
looked at him i was like huh
and he was like yeah like i watched
wrestling too like you're doing a
wrestling move and i was like super
embarrassed
and then we stopped fighting and i was
like man
you know what afterwards yeah we got to
became friends afterwards you bonded
over that yeah
hey you want to come over for royal
rumble later yeah i was like well i
didn't know you watched
hbk shawn michaels
dude there's like there's some some
creative ass characters at that
wrestling match i went to there's a guy
called the grim reaper
he's hella weak and gets his ass kicked
until he [ __ ] puts a joint
oh my god
he powers up that's like the modern
popeye yeah dude
that's a better version of that it was
so covert the way he brought it out
you didn't even see him like take it out
he just got [ __ ] his ass whooped and
then at some point he was just like
getting up and he [ __ ] had it in his
mouth
and just tore the other and everyone's
all scared they're like no he's powerful
he's blowing [ __ ] o's and [ __ ] yeah
and everybody in the place knows that
he's gonna do it so they're all like
cheering they're just waiting for that
moment
you guys i'm telling you we'd have so
much fun bro yeah the characters are
[ __ ] genius now yeah do we have uh
[ __ ] wrestling if we don't have that
i'm not going well that's called it's
called like tiny nitro or something my
buddy was actually a tiny nitro
something like that my buddy said it to
me yeah like recently that's funny and i
was like i'm not gonna go see this dude
but now i'm looking i'm kind of
intrigued ever since ryan said this is
an rc car tiny nice road
something it's tiny something like that
it's in the name it's a great name i
wish i knew what it was
let's go
wcw mini nitro is that one of those mini
nitrogen is that what it is
yeah look at look at this just look at
this little clip
this is the [ __ ] thing you got to
move out of the way
he went down
ty
but that's just like one thing and it's
it's it's insane let's go let's go those
guys throw their bodies man wait like
the coolest thing is i'd always expect
it when i go to wrestling show it's
gonna be full of like bro testosterone
people absolutely not like it's just
cool ass dudes because then i also
forgot that a lot of wrestling fans are
kind of more on like the nerdy side so
they're actually like just really nice
guys and everybody it's like being a
catholic church they all know what to
yell when yeah most of my buddies that
are like wrestling fans they're kind of
nerdy you know it's like they're not
like really brilliant
no i think there's like something really
cool about wrestling because it's like
your sense of escape from the world
you're seeing this like this like this
whole like almost like act i think
somebody related like wrestling almost
like the guy's version of soap operas
yeah and you just get lost in the story
you find fans and you start cheering
it's like when you see people doing the
wave you know everyone's gonna be doing
the wave right so it seems like
wrestling i think there's something like
so innocent and like fun about that
that's true i think i quit too early man
and it's at the ukrainian cultural
center so you feel like you're doing
your part
do
[Music]
i'm